l'expression gendarme du monde revient
régulièrement dans les médias pour
qualifier les états unis elle est
utilisée par de nombreuses personnalités
politiques et par des analystes qui
voient d'un mauvais oeil les décisions
unilatérales de washington en matière de
géopolitique par la phrase ce chef
d'état n'est pas légitime nous ne le
reconnaissons pas il faut comprendre si
un autre chef d'état qui nous convient
mieux ne le remplace pas dans les plus
brefs délais nous prendrons des
dispositions afin que cela se fasse
s'ensuivent des sanctions économiques
qui étouffe l'état en question qui
connaît alors des troubles politiques et
se retrouve de ce fait pour un temps au
banc du monde
scénario classique presque toujours les
décisions américaines sont aussitôt
appuyé par bruxelles fidèle allié
politique de washington
sauf que ces dernières années ce
scénario classique semble patiner de
plus en plus exemple avec le venezuela
le président nicolas maduro est l'ennemi
numéro 1 de washington dans la région
chavistes bolivarien anti impérialiste
il a le profil type du chef d'état
écartés d'autant plus qu'il est à la
tête d'un pays qui possède l'une des
plus importantes réserves de pétrole au
monde
washington lui avait même trouvé un
remplaçant wang wade au président par
intérim entre guillemets depuis janvier
2019 et soutenue par une cinquantaine de
pays dont la france
mais malgré les sanctions draconiennes
imposées au venezuela pour placer
gouaille dos à sa tête
maduro reste en place et washington est
dans l'impasse il invite désormais son
protégé à se faire plus discret parce
qu'il a une autre idée la mise en place
d'un conseil d'état qui sera chargé
d'organiser une élection présidentielle
anticipée d'ici six à douze mois
mais quel est l'intérêt est organisée
une élection à laquelle madonna aurait
le droit de se présenter puisqu'il est
hors de question qu'ils soient élus de
toute façon nos sanctions resteront en
vigueur et seront renforcés jusqu'à ce
que le régime maduro accepte une vraie
transition politique
donc en réalité cela ne veut rien dire
élections ou non tant que maduro ne se
pliera pas à la volonté de washington
les sanctions continueront à s'appliquer
autre exemple et non des moindres la
syrie après des années de guerre et de
déclarations du type monsieur bachar al
assad ne mériterait pas des priorités
oui bof mais la politique de washington
et ses alliés dans la région a bien
changé de plus l' ingérence pratiqué par
les états unis aient lieu en syrie a
rendu leur influence dans le pays quasi
nul
contrairement à celle de la russie par
exemple on peut se demander ce que
washington et bruxelles comptent faire
lorsqu'il affirme solennellement ne pas
reconnaître la réélection d'alexandre
loukachenko
compte-t-il imposé des sanctions
économiques à son pays on peut douter
que cela plaise aux biélorusses proposer
un homme providentiel pour gouverner la
biélorussie peu de chances que ce soit
ce que souhaite la population pour
laquelle un scénario à l'ukrainienne
avec une partition du territoire serait
une catastrophe
sinon il reste l'option brasser de l'air
éventuellement